domestic water that's provided to our
homes today comes through a series of
water treatment processes and piping and
pumps and you know things that bring
that water to us today and then the
wastewater is returned back to treatment
to treatment plants a couple of
challenges those municipalities are
facing one is that the infrastructure is
aging it's leaking there's between a lot
of cities have between 30 and 60 percent
of the water that they produce never
makes it to the end of the line because
it leaks out of these pipes it's
difficult for them to replace it because
there just isn't the reserve the revenue
to be able to invest in this replacement
one of the other challenges is it's very
energy intensive between three and
twenty percent of a typical
municipalities budget goes to energy to
produce and pump this water around so we
look at smart grid type of technology
not unlike we see in the energy smart
grid is necessary for water to really to
improve this system part of that is to
be able to detect where are these leaks
to be able to be predictive to get out
ahead so instead of waiting for a leak
to occur and having that you know all of
the emergency digging up the roads you
know all the problems that that might
cause be nice to be able to predict when
might that failure occur to be able to
predict what are the costs over the next
year or the next decade in that that
infrastructure we as consumers if we
really understood where our water was
was going and we had some control over
that and we could you know use the water
and off-peak hours all the same type of
things that we try to do with the energy
grid I think it would really improve our
overall consumptive habits of water
another thing is that there the water
pricing structure is it's a real
challenge for us today many parts of the
world including many parts of United
States basically water is free and so as
long as water is free or highly
subsidized there's really there's
there's kind of no incentive for us to
reduce our consumption or change our
behaviors so I think a smart system
would give us that insight that we need
to really change behaviors because I do
think people want to want to be smart
consumers of our water but without that
information it's very difficult to make
those those smart decisions
there's a lot of really smart
technologies being deployed now in
cities a couple of examples a Singapore
has been brilliant in the way that
they're thinking about their have the
overall broad scope of their water
system for many years Singapore relied
on Malaysia for the supply of their
water a giant pipeline coming from
Malaysia to Singapore and over the last
decade or so they've been very proactive
in trying to diversify their water
supply so for instance they now have a
program they refer to as the four taps
they have four different ways that they
get water one is that pipeline from
Malaysia the second is through very
advanced reuse water wastewater reuse
technologies that they've deployed so
that a significant portion of their over
water overall water supply actually
comes from treated waste water streams
fantastic technology the third is around
the capture of rainwater you know a lot
of rain in Singapore but most of it runs
off so now what they've been able to do
is build a series of reservoirs and
catchment basins to catch in purify that
water and then forth they use
desalination technology to kind of make
up the difference so between these four
various technologies smart
infrastructure system to monitor they
really are brilliant in the way they've
put a long-term plan together around
their water supply